schritte aus den shutdown mit viel tests
und vorsicht will die politik langsam
zurück zum alltag
deutsch-französische belastungsprobe
die strecke ohne regeln an der grenze
zum saarland verärgern nicht nur die
berufspendler auf der spur zu silber und
bronze
die deutschen snowboarderinnen beweisen
bei der wm in slowenien ihre extraklasse
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am dienstag auch
rudi cerne ist wieder dabei für den
sport hallo schön guten abend einen tag
vor dem mit spannung erwarteten
bund-länder-treffen circa bonner politik
soll sich die bundeskanzlerin intern für
vorsichtige öffnungen ausgesprochen
haben
die menschen wünschten diese sehnlichst
aber man brauche eine notbremse wenn die
zahlen wieder rauf gingen nach dem
entwurf aus dem kanzleramt soll der
shutdown in vier schritten aufgehoben
werden flankiert von vielen tests und
impfungen thomas reichert sie wollen
wieder öffnen der einzelhandel seit
wochen geschlossen kämpft ums überleben
und fordert nun wie hier in berlin
lockerungen man kann überall einkaufen
gehen beim lebensmittler überall kriegt
man die produkte und wir stehen gehalten
und haben super hygiene konzepte und
dürfen leider nicht an start gehen doch
der beschluss entwürfe die konferenz
morgen verlängert den schotter und
erstmal bis ende märz und lag nur
vorsichtige öffnungen nach dem entwurf
werden ab nächster woche wieder treffen
mit einem weiteren haushalt möglich
buchhandlungen blumengeschäfte und
gartenmärkte dürften deutschlandweit
wieder öffnen
ebenso flug und fahrschulen weitere
öffnungen aber sieht der entwurf erst
vor wenn die inzidenz unter 35 liegt zum
ersten mal gibt es damit eine
perspektive für weitere öffnungen bei
guten werten strittig ist wie weit das
geht jetzt haben wir glaube ich viele
menschen lange genug warten lassen und
von daher ist es für mich absolut
unabdingbar dass wir morgen einen
solchen stufen und perspektiv plan
verabschieden bei schulen und kitas
richten sich alle hoffnungen auf
schnelltests die es bis anfang april
deutschlandweit geben soll
ein oder zwei pro schüler pro woche sagt
der entwurf und fordern die länder wenn
wir gleichzeitig die erzieher und lehrer
noch mit dem impfen absichern ist
vielmehr kita und schule möglich auch
bei höheren instanzen eine abkehr von
der strengen im verein folge um liegen
gebliebene dosen für andere zu nutzen
lehnte entwurf strikt ab die linke
forderte weiter dass andere neue
impfstoffe und schneller verfügbar sein
sollen
ich erwarte von der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dass die
zulassungskriterien auch
die impfstoffe verändert werden ich bin
immer einigermaßen erstaunt wenn dinge
in europa erst später zugelassen werden
als in den usa in großbritannien es wird
wohl ein hartes ringen morgen um diese
frage wieviel eröffnung ist möglich dank
testen und ins navi viel öffnung ist
möglich die erwartungen sind so hoch wie
nie hat man das gefühl hat gunther love
energy wird man denn mit konkreten
antworten rechnen können wenn bund und
länder bei den beschluss bleiben der uns
jetzt der zeit vorliegt dann ja also es
wird wahrscheinlich nicht alle zufrieden
stellen denn auch dieser beschluss sieht
nur vorsichtige lockerungen vor aber sie
beugen sich dort immerhin über etwas was
die gesellschaft schon lange fordert
nämlich über eine langfristperspektive
es ist dort skizziert ein umfassender
öffnungs plan auch ein detaillierter
öffnungs plan einige stellen sind noch
offen über die muss morgen noch
verhandelt werden aber das könnte eben
mehr sicherheit für die perspektive
geben mehr ausblick darauf wie es in den
nächsten monaten kommen könnte das ganze
hat allerdings zwei große haken es wird
nur funktionieren wenn das testen und
das impfen auch funktionieren und da
hören wir dass es im hintergrund große
debatten darüber gibt ob deutschland
tatsächlich schon richtig aufgestellt
ist und die mutanten die sich ausbreiten
die dürfen nicht schneller sein
wir hören heute dass angela merkel in
der unions-bundestagsfraktion gewarnt
hat die britische mutante sei jetzt
schon bei 50 also dass beides muss
funktionieren und man muss sich
natürlich morgen auch erst noch einigen
wir morgen um diese zeit wissen wir
vielleicht schon mehr vielen dank und
ella unter den kontakt beschränkungen
leiden vor allem die rund eine million
bewohner der alten und pflegeheime in
deutschland
sie gehören zu den besonders
schützenswerten in der ersten impf
gruppe gut 81 prozent von ihnen wurden
schon mindestens einmal geimpft und so
gibt es dort auch kaum noch infizierte
oder corona todesfälle nun endlich
könnten die besuchs einschränkungen
gelockert werden dominik müller marcel
täglich besucht winfried hahn seine
demente frau helga im seniorenheim der
diakonie michaelshoven bei quelle
ein stein vom herzen gefallen seit seine
frau zum zweiten mal geimpft ist
nun wartet wie free zahn darauf dass sie
die masten auf dem gelände wieder
abziehen dürfen und auch die
gemeinschaftsräume wieder öffnen damit
er mit seiner frau mal wieder einen
kaffee trinken kann
das hatten wir alle gehofft wenn jetzt
alle mal geimpft sind
und wenn zwei drei wochen vergangen sind
das dann dadurch eine immunität war wäre
und da meine ich da müsste eigentlich
unbedingt jetzt irgendwas erwartet
werden doch nach wie vor gelten die
gleichen strengen regeln masten pflicht
abstand und engmaschige schnelltests für
bewohnern pflegekräfte und besucher auch
die betreiber dringe nun wieder auf mehr
normalität
es geht um erleichterungen beim
zusammenleben in einer einrichtung also
miteinander singen gottesdienst feiern
miteinander basteln am tisch sitzen ohne
plexiglasscheibe dazwischen aber auch um
test frequenzen wie häufig getestet
werden muss pflegeeinrichtungen waren
pandemie treiber entsprechend schwer tut
sich die politik mit lockerungen dennoch
schlagen die landesgesundheitsminister
nun vorsichtige erleichterungen vor
angesichts des im fortschritt denn das
sehe ich schon dass man da das impfen
auch die sinn haben muss dass das leben
für die alten menschen wieder schöner
wird getestet werden soll nach wie vor
eng nicht doch besuchs regeln könnten
gelockert werden vielleicht ist auch ein
gemeinsamer café bald wieder drin
das wäre wünschenswert zumal die korona
neuinfektion derzeit ja praktisch
stagnieren
dennoch warnen die ärzteverbände davor
zu schnell und unkoordiniert zu öffnen
das virus sei immer schneller als alle
maßnahmen und negative testergebnisse
können menschen auch in falscher
sicherheit wiegen volker dutschek
constantin ist 10 und fast schon so
etwas wie ein alter hase im umgang mit
dem kleinen städtchen in der grundschule
neubiberg südlich von münchen gibt es
bereits schnelltests
[Musik]
fast 80 prozent der eltern hier sind
nach angaben der schule für regelmäßige
schnell untersuchung lehrer und schüler
tragen die testerei noch mit fassung wir
sind eigentlich recht zufrieden wie wir
diese krise bis jetzt gemeistert haben
freuen uns aber schon darauf wenn wir
dann irgendwann wieder in den
normalzustand übergehen können es gibt
aber auch stimmen die davor warnen
schüler massenhaft zu testen
kinderärzte wie dr thomas fischbach
halten flächendeckende schnelltests für
unsinnig er sagt negativer tests führten
nur dazu dass sich alle sicher fühlten
und sich keiner mehr an die
abstandsregeln halte wir plädieren er
dafür symptomatische patienten natürlich
zu test und zwar sehr frühzeitig und
eben das betreuungspersonal das dann
durchaus zwei mal in der woche
der kampf gegen korona macht jetzt auch
sowas möglich eine sonder impfaktion
weil 1200 dosen des astra zenica
impfstoffs übrig blieben hat die stadt
krefeld pädagoginnen aus kitas und
grundschulen spontan eingeladen
ein beispiel das bundesweit schule
machen könnte schon hat mecklenburg
vorpommern angekündigt menschen aus
anderen gruppen vorzuziehen falls
künftig dosen übrig sind
und jetzt schauen wir an die deutsch
französische grenze seit mitternacht
gelten für die region mosel neue strenge
einreise regeln nur mit einem aktuellen
negativen corona test dürfen die
menschen aus modell noch einreisen nach
rheinland pfalz und ins saarland
so will man die ausbreitung der mutation
eindämmen doch die deutschen maßnahmen
führen vor ort nicht nur zu problemen
sondern auch zu politischem streit
mehr dazu von thomas walde anstellen zum
cupid test die deutsch-französische
grenze wird für berufspendler zum
händler und ärgernis ein test alle zwei
tage
dreimal die woche bei so einer schlange
die deutsche seite sagt man habe handeln
müssen würde es in frankreich viele
infektionen gibt und virusvarianten aber
auch feste kontrollen verzichtet ein
test durch zu
das ist doch jetzt wirklich nicht ein
großes problem
eine grenze zwei ansichten keine
stationären grenzkontrollen auf deutsch
kälte zwischen paris und berlin wegen
der wiedereinführung von kontrollen auf
französisch treten ganz konkret ähnelt
das einer faktischen grenzschließung
auch wenn die kontrolle nur im
hinterland durchgeführt werden diese
einseitige und brutale entscheidung aus
berlin überrascht uns sehr
juli mo pathos infektionen nehmen in
weiten teilen frankreichs zu ein jahr
vor der wahl scheut präsident max
strengere einschnitte und schwäche macht
empfindlich wann wird eigentlich täglich
mit neuen unsicherheiten konfrontiert
und das hat natürlich auch
wahrscheinlich diesen sensibilitäten
nicht geholfen dass man jetzt wieder
eine neue entscheidung hat und da kommt
ostdeutschland die nachricht frankreich
ist zu gefährlich das hört
wahrscheinlich niemand gerne
infektionszahlen und sensibilitäten
prallen aufeinander darum sehen
frankreich und deutschland derzeit etwas
unterschiedliches wenn sie auf die
gemeinsame grenze blicken
die organisation reporter ohne grenzen
hat saudi arabiens kronprinz bin salman
angezeigt beim generalbundesanwalt in
karlsruhe bin salman sei
hauptverantwortlich für den mord an dem
saudischen journalisten kvg das und die
systematische verfolgung weitere
journalisten sei ein verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit
seit 2002 können solche verbrechen in
deutschland auch dann verfolgt werden
wenn sie im ausland verübt wurden
um die meinungsfreiheit in china steht
es schlecht
ausländische journalisten werden immer
wieder systematisch behindert
eingeschüchtert und drangsaliert sie
klagen über einen raschen verfall der
pressefreiheit das geht aus ihrer
jährlichen befragung hervor
zdf korrespondent ulf röller über eigene
erfahrungen und die von kolleginnen und
kollegen
er hat die macht des chinesischen
sicherheitsapparates zu spüren bekommen
der australische tv journalist bill
bertels der für fünf jahre aus peking
berichtete
sieben polizisten kamen nachts zu mir
nach hause und erklärten mir ich dürfe
das land nicht verlassen
die chinesen wollten bertels über eine
kollegin befragen erst nach seiner
aussage durfte er ausreisen
in seinem jahresbericht beklagt der club
der auslandskorrespondenten den verfall
der pressefreiheit in china
wörtlich der staat hat alle zur
verfügung stehenden mittel eingesetzt um
die journalisten und ihre chinesischen
kollegen zu belästigen und
einzuschüchtern
auch wir erleben dass fast täglich das
behindern unserer dreharbeiten der
versuch material zu beschlagnahmen und
das einschüchtern von interviewpartnern
der bericht zeigt dass es immer
schwieriger wird unabhängige
informationen aus china zu bekommen
das aussenministerium bestreitet dass
china die auslandskorrespondenten
systematisch verfolgt china wehrt sich
gegen ideologische voreingenommenheit
wir sind gegen fake news im namen der
pressefreiheit in knapp einem jahr will
sich china zu den olympischen
winterspielen weltoffen präsentieren
kaum vorstellbar denn es herrscht in
diesem land immer mehr ein klima der
einschüchterung der arbeitsmarkt in
deutschland bleibt recht stabil trotz
des weitgehenden shutdown wichtigster
grund dafür ist die kurzarbeit die
entlassungen vermeiden hilft nach
angaben der bundesagentur für arbeit
waren zwei millionen 900 4000 menschen
ohne job das sind 4000 mehr als im
januar
die quote liegt unverändert bei 63
prozent gegenüber dem februar des
vergangenen jahres ist die zahl der
arbeitslosen um 500 9000 gestiegen
mitten in der korona krise steuert die
metall und elektroindustrie auf eine
harte tarifrunde zu die ig metall hatte
heute zu warnstreiks in vielen betrieben
aufgerufen
sie fordert vier prozent mehr lohn den
arbeitgebern wirft sie vor belastungen
durch die pandemie einseitig den
beschäftigten aufbürden zu wollen
die arbeitgeber wollen eine nullrunde
und darüber hinaus ausnahmen vom
tarifvertrag im vergangenen frühjahr
schütteten mehrere anschläge eine
kleinstadt in bayern
jetzt hat der prozess gegen einen
mutmaßlichen es anhänger begonnen
waldkraiburg liegt etwa 60 kilometer
östlich von münchen und war schauplatz
einer ganzen serie von angriffen auf
türkische läden und restaurants getötet
wurde dabei glücklicherweise niemand
heute gestand der angeklagte ein
deutscher mit kurdischen wurzeln noch
weitere große anschläge vorbereitet zu
haben petra neubauer
er habe erst in der untersuchungshaft
wieder einen klaren kopf bekommen
erklärt noir in der an diesem ersten
prozesstag und das alles was die anklage
anführe
richtig sei animiert hätten ihn videos
im internet der angeklagte ist in
deutschland ja geboren das soll sich
auch hier in deutschland radikalisiert
haben
die ersten taten die ihm hierzu last
liegen datieren aus dem jahr 2017 schon
als er die ersten utensilien beschafft
haben soll um bomben zu bauen
material für anschläge auf türkische
geschäfte der verheerendste trifft im
vergangenen april einen gemüseladen und
die wohnungen darüber nur durch glück
bleibt es bei vier verletzten
als der angeklagte festgenommen wird
finden die beamten 23 rohrbomben
kiloweise sprengstoff und eine pistole
für weitere anschläge etwa auf die
zentralmoschee in köln
das tatmotiv des angeklagten war nach
dem ergebnis der ermittlungen eine
radikalislamistische weltanschauung und
eine darauf gestützte von ihm selbst so
bezeichnete türken hass moar md
entschuldigt sich heute bei vertretern
der opfer aber bleiben zweifel ist schon
so ein bisschen irritierend wenn jemand
sein bedauern aus spricht auch mit blick
auf die geschädigten es der anschläge
auf der anderen seite sich weigert
fragen eben dieser menschen zu
beantworten
immer wieder verstrickt sich der
angeklagte in widersprüche seine
verteidiger begründen das mit einer
psychischen erkrankung viel
klärungsbedarf für das gericht in den
kommenden gut 40 verhandlungstagen die
meisten unserer nutztiere leiden zu
wenig platz im stall schlechte luft
schlechtes futter aber bessere
verhältnisse wären zu teuer heißt es oft
eine studie aus dem agrarministerium
sieht jetzt zwei mögliche wege zu mehr
tierwohl durch eine neue verbraucher
steuer etwa könnten die bauern beim
umbau der stelle finanziell unterstützt
werden oder variante 2 durch das anheben
der mehrwertsteuer auf tierische
produkte
derzeit gilt der ermäßigte satz von
sieben prozent
er könnte auf den normalen satz also 19
prozent angehoben werden
zum sport mit fußball und erfolgreichen
deutschen wintersportler rudi haben
einen richtig guten lauf silber und
bronze für zwei deutsche
snowboarderinnen bei der wm in rogla
slowenien ramona hofmeister aus
bischofswiesen fährt im parallel slalom
auf platz zwei selina jörg aus sonthofen
auf den dritten rang
weltmeisterin wird die russin sofia der
china dieser fehler brachte ramona
hofmeister raus aus der spur und aus dem
rennen
so verpasste sie den sieg gegen russland
erst 17 jähriges talent sofia nati china
die vor zu gold und erfüllte sich ihren
traum vom weltmeistertitel überlegen
trotzdem silber für hofmeister ihr
bislang größter erfolg bei einer wm
es fühlt sich wirklich unglaublich auch
mit dem ziel ihn jetzt wieder oben zu
stehen die gäste weltmeisterin worden es
ist wirklich wahnsinn
selina jörg gewann im kleinen finale
bronze ihre zweite medaille nach ihrem
parallel riesenslalom gold gestern neue
personalien in der fußball bundesliga
sportvorstand fredi bobic will nach
übereinstimmenden medienberichten
eintracht frankfurt im sommer verlassen
hertha bsc könnte das ziel sein und bei
schalke 04 ist der ehemalige darmstädter
demetrius grammatik favorit für den
vakanten trainerposten definitiv
bestätigt frank kramer der frühere dfb
junioren coach übernimmt die nachfolge
von uwe neuhaus bei arminia bielefeld
heute abend kommt es im dfb pokal
viertelfinale borussia mönchengladbach
gegen borussia dortmund zu einem
pikanten trainerduell der künftige bvb
cheftrainer marco rose gegen seinen
assistenten in spe den tisch
im januar haben sich dortmunds noch
cheftrainer tätig und sein künftiger
baus rose schon einmal kennengelernt
marco rose persönlich kenne ich noch
nicht so gut aber das was ich
kennengelernt habe was das was ich
mitbekommen habe
es ist ein sehr sympathischer kerl der
sehr guten fußball spielen lässt wie
auch im bundesliga duell im januar als
großes gladbacher mit 4 2 gewannen
zwar hat gladbach nach verkündung von
roses weggang nur noch niederlagen
kassiert zuletzt in leipzig doch aus dem
januar sie gegen dortmund schöpf große
hoffnung das ist wichtig dass wir an
einem guten tag wo viele dinge für uns
zusammen passen
eine mannschaft borussia dortmund
besiegen können ansonsten aber dürfte
der scheidende gladbach-trainer ziemlich
im regen stehen
ja das wasser vom sport danke rudi und
wir haben zum schluss noch etwas da
geht's um malerei weltkriegs diplomatie
showbiz und viel geld konkret um dieses
gemälde nämlich die moschee von
marrakesch der künstler winston
churchill hauptberuflich britischer
premier er hatte das bild 1943 nach
casablanca konferenz gemalt und us
präsident roosevelt geschickt über
umwege gelangte es in den besitz von
angelina jolie die es jetzt versteigern
dies der preis fast 9,5 millionen euro
ob das gemälde wieder in prominente
hände kam ist unbekannt
viele talente hatte dieser mann zum
wetter es wird vorübergehend milder und
frühlingshafte mehr gleich von essent
ali
das war es von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren bettina schausten erwartet sie um
21 uhr 45 im heute-journal und wir
freuen uns wenn sie auch morgen wieder
einschalten um 19 uhr einen schönen
abend wünschen wie chips
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter aus dem süden
europas erreicht uns noch etwas mildere
luft mit dem tief hier und das hoch das
verabschiedet sich langsam trotzdem gibt
es morgen noch einmal ganz viel
sonnenschein von norden kündigt sich
kalte luft an die erreicht uns aber erst
am donnerstag in der nacht bildet sich
teils dichter nebel nach norden
im osten gibt es auch nebel sonst ist es
sternenklar und die temperaturen sinken
bis auf minus fünf grad im südosten
deutschlands minus vier grad an der elbe
und +5 grad ganz im westen deutschlands
morgen tagesverlauf viel sonnenschein
vor allem in der mitte und im süden im
westen gibt harmlose bewölkung im norden
ist die bewölkung dichter aber insgesamt
ist es trocken bei höchsten temperaturen
von fünf bis acht grad ganz im norden
aber schauen sie mal sonst 14 bis 16
teilt 18 grad im westen deutschlands und
19 grad am oberrhein
das ist ungewöhnlich mit und die
nächsten tage
am donnerstag erreichte uns die kaltluft
von norden her es gibt regen es gibt
schauer teilweise auch gewitter bei 4
bis 16 grad und dann sinkt die
schneefallgrenze und in den
mittelgebirgen in den im osten da kann
es durchaus sogar schnee geben bei 1 bis
8 grad
ein schöner abend